[Música]
Pero antes vamos a nuestra revista de
prensa con Marta Moya Marta Buen día
para usted un saludo Hola Ángela Buenos
días Pues bueno el tema que nos ocupa el
día de hoy en esta mañana es el Reino
Unido conocimos el viernes que el
presidente de una de las cadenas
públicas más famosas del mundo la bbc
anunció su retiro después de una sonada
noticia en la que se confirmó que sí
hubo conflicto de intereses y que sí
entregó unas donaciones que no quedaron
registradas en ninguna parte si Ángela
nos referimos a Richard sharp el hasta
ahora presidente de la pbc que ha
presentado este viernes su renuncia
después de la publicación de un informe
en el que se dice que violó el código de
gobierno para los nombramientos públicos
por no revelar que había participado en
la facilitación de un préstamo a Boris
Johnson cuando este era Primer Ministro
para todo esto nos tenemos que remontar
a enero cuando el semanario Sunday Times
publicó una nota en la que invertía que
Boris Johnson había presentado a sharp
como presidente de la bbc muy pocas
semanas después de que este señor ex
banquero y donante del partido
conservador hiciera una donación de
cerca de un millón de dólares al
entonces Primer Ministro de Reino Unido
a finales esto el estado nación a
finales de 2020 el informe que ha sido
catalizador para que share presentara su
renuncia dice que también hubo conflicto
de intereses Por una parte por decirle a
Johnson que se quería postular como
presidente antes de que Johnson le
propusiera y por otra parte por
organizar una reunión entre el entonces
más alto funcionario de Reino Unido y un
primo lejano de Boris Johnson para
discutir sobre el préstamo al Primer
Ministro hemos destacado también un
artículo de la revista bariety que dice
que sharp va a continuar siendo
presidente en funciones hasta junio pero
que el Gobierno ya está trabajando en
reemplazo y además dice desde la bbc que
están satisfechos con la labor que ha
desempeñado como presidente de la
corporación y sharp dice que todo esto
no fue más que un descuido Y también
hemos destacado un artículo del
Washington post que dice que todo este
episodio es la última de las polémicas
en torno a la bbc y sobre todo cuando la
bbc está a cargo de una de las
coberturas más importantes de su
historia la próxima semana con la
coronación de Carlos III y en marzo
también hubo otro gran episodio de
polémica cuando se suspendió a la gran
estrella de los deportes a Gary linecker
por hacer comentarios criticando la
política migratoria del gobierno y que
esto ponía en duda la neutralidad y la
imparcialidad del abc Aunque luego Fue
readmitido entonces mucha polémica en
los últimos meses en torno a la cadena
pública británica es que eso le iba a
decir justamente es que son pocas
semanas entre una polémica y otra en la
cadena que es conocida históricamente
por su gran neutralidad y por ser el
Informador del Reino Unido y además como
así que se le olvidó reportar un millón
de dólares es que no es no parece que
fuera inocente no se sale de todo bueno
Marta vamos a cambiar hora de tema en
los últimos días ha habido mucha
polémica porque diversos medios de
comunicación entre ellos el tabloide de
dail publicaron la noticia sobre la
muerte de un presunto actor canadiense
que habría fallecido después de
realizarse múltiples cirugías para
parecerse a a una estrella del pop Sur
coreano Ahora parece que todo esto
podría haber sido producto de la
Inteligencia artificial cuéntenos sí
Ángela una noticia que de verdad no es
capaz la Fantasía pero que también da
signos de preocupación nos referimos a
un presunto actor y digo presunto porque
esto avanza que sea más colucci que es
canadiense portugués y que tendría
presencia en la escena del
entretenimiento surcoreano a principios
de esta semana una agencia de
comunicación publica que este actor de
22 años ha fal después de someterse a
nada más y nada menos que 12 operaciones
valoradas en aproximadamente 200 mil
dólares para cambiar sus rasgos faciales
y parecerse no a este a estos ídolos del
pop Sur coreano el problema viene cuando
parece que este señor nunca ha existido
y que todo es producto de una creación
de la Inteligencia artificial y
preocupante también que muchos medios de
comunicación se hicieron Eco De esa
publicación de esa agencia de
comunicación anunciando esa muerte y
después esto ha traído mucha polémica
consigo porque los signos de que todo
esto es fake son primero que las
imágenes de él están totalmente
distorsionadas que el acceso a las
fuentes en internet no cargan que este
presunto actor no tiene redes sociales
que el comunicado está plagado de
errores y que la discografía de este
presunto actor y cantante no existe
ninguna plataforma no además el Quizá es
que el Daily mail después de publicar
esta noticia que fue el primer medio en
hacerlo borro el miércoles la noticia
Sin dar ningún tipo de explicación sin
ni siquiera pronunciarse ni dar un
comunicado de disculpas por publicar lo
que todo aparenta es una noticia falsa
Pues bueno aquí varias cosas fíjese que
a mí me cuesta bastante informarme con
el Daily mail no sería mi primer medio
de referencia y Y pues también quitar un
poco el pánico con todos estos temas en
otros Muchos medios no que es lo
preocupante Claro pero es que ahí uno
piensa se preocupa por la Inteligencia
artificial pero yo creo que es más un
tema de rigurosidad no de verificación
de las fuentes y ahí los que fallamos
somos contraste de cómo verificamos
nuestras Fuentes Cuando hacemos noticias
entonces responsabilidad del informarnos
Y por supuesto responsabilidades de los
que estamos informando Marta vamos a
terminar con un artículo del país el
periodista Enrique Enrique Perdón al
pañez que titula capitalismo de perritos
como la popularidad del bulldog francés
pone en evidencia la brutalidad de la
industria de mascotas Y qué gran tema
para determinar si Ángela un tema muy de
viernes pero también muy curioso el
artículo del país empieza así en junio
de 2020 un avión de Ucrania en
International Airlines aterrizó en
Toronto desde fuera Parecía un vuelo
normal pero en su interior se
desarrollaba una escena dantesca 500
cachorros de bulldog francés lloraban en
sus jaulas muchos estaban deshidratados
débiles y jadeantes 38 de ellos estaban
muertos este artículo del país denuncia
el aumento de tráfico ilegal de esta
raza de perros incrementado para hacer
frente a la alta demanda de este tipo de
perros no por ejemplo en Estados Unidos
sostiene este artículo del país las
inscripciones de bulldog francés han
aumentado en más de 1.000 por ciento y
países como Ucrania letonia Polonia
Hungría Serbia Rumanía o Bulgaria sirven
de criaderos es sin muchos escrúpulos de
este tipo de razas según un informe
reciente sobre contrabando de esto
también ha llevado a que naciones como
Países Bajos prohíba la expedición de
pedigrí a la raza de bulldog francés y
también de carlinos y además después de
la muerte de algunos de estos perros en
aviones algunas aerolíneas han prohibido
que estos perros vuelen en vuelos
comerciales el artículo del país termina
diciendo que un perro se ponga de moda y
supone una condena genética para la raza
y una lotería para los criaderos quizás
sería el momento de preguntarse qué dice
de nosotros haber pagado miles de euros
para comprar un perro con evidentes
problemas de salud y una corta esperanza
de vida solo porque lo vimos en un
anuncio y nos pareció mono quizá sería
el momento Gracias por esa reflexión
Marta y pues al periodista que la
publica y nos vemos la próxima semana
gracias